ready you ready you ready let's do you
right to it alright here we go this is
gonna be a good one man so the winner of
this is gonna be going up against
Ireland's book talent book man without
winners finals second vault all secured
hope you guys are home enjoy an empty
share the stream and I want us going on
hey this isn't even the mean of me crazy
does it just the last chance qualifier
where someone gets to go to the main
event
yeah it's still so much more second
action this weekend it's been a good one
so what do you think about this man so I
know obviously you know kagemaru very
well being in Japan like how many a
creamers are there I mean what have they
been doing I didn't practice I mean he's
you know have you seen any Akuma it
feels like recently it's more it's been
more just practicing the match up having
other players that have played the
character it's just not to the level of
what you've been seeing on Tekken Walt
or especially in the past 18 months
right and that's the issue I think in
Korea as well they haven't got any
stronger coolest so to be able to get
that high level practice been hard yeah
but like you said they have done their
homework and it's showing here you've
seen a lot of the players that maybe
played him before had some experience
with them before they've gone to the lab
just specifically to be able to give
other people they help an experience to
be able to get more familiar yell out
these situations so kagemaru don't with
the Joseon you know gee we have seen
Josie verses of humor I'm assuming
that's what's gonna be the matchup yeah
and you seen black beard versus super
humor so many times you know Europe had
exposure to Akuma for a long time having
superhuman air and I feel like Josie has
really good options down for to hop car
hop kickin beat Deva fit very well if
target Mara's ready for this you could
definitely do
and I feel like a lot of the players
that have beaten Paxton in his term have
been the Japanese players actually yeah
well I'll tell you what awesome topic
right and like I said many times a lot
of my information comes from Austin
right sure
he said that you know if you want to
beat these Pakistani players you just
want to go for that rule fifty-fifty
like you just want to do that like a
Josie's it's what cocky war has been
doing you did it versus that John I
believe you people able to lose this
just for 50/50 I'm going for the crash 2
crash 3
he doesn't care coffee bar just talking
about [ __ ] he will just go in and I
think that's really thrown off
somebody's Pakistani players
oh here we go again theme started here
what character blog going ok cool
alright I think that's what we're gonna
see we're gonna see him using whom
unless he needs to pull out Brian for
that's kind of what we saw earlier if
it's a three zip then I think he will
changed yeah
so the strategy to keep marking with a
given one round hey baby
throw a away man like I want to keep on
this Akuma make it close Pat open sweep
from belong to
Karam are definitely up to something he
was trying to thread a needle there with
that downpour - yeah preemptively oh
yeah you write 50 psi baby that's that
man I saw you was a that's why he beat a
lot of these players might as well 50/50
who's guessing right yeah Strunk Mikey
and the thing is over law was so ready
with that he got the nice back 114 frame
bunny bunny she was ready for it
yep Cass County v delay tech toe kick
there how do we get the win reach that
was the most confident Jeff I'm Co there
he punched her in the nose slide in low
gotta be careful with a cache I figure
that down - yeah it wasn't fast enough
to punish it yeah
I love Jeff he's proud you're so loud
your theater is awesome yeah there was
super loud even downstairs as well it's
not a most trip either it's like no so a
seven-hour flight from here down is
heavy come talking borrowed the board
what authority yeah definitely last year
and even the year before
definitely Chafee crowd at least like 20
at least 20 players came out here use
that eater you seems like these Japanese
guys are also truly post each other as
well as people to see here checks good
law fighting for his life with this wall
behind him good defense now hold it up
the patient's oh that was a big chunk of
his job hey no wow sign is low Obama in
here sweetie
please keep out there with a standing
three target Maru one round away from
taking the first match cast a lot bring
it back this is where the fight starts
oh he is close to full meter here you
cannot make big risks with lows here oh
my god never mind perfect you talk time
down to there but I'll take it to the
wall Oh
reset beat up the combo count he'll the
what watch the Tatsu wall that once
again no one just testing a minute and
the time to close it out everything just
worked out in his favor that last round
but managed to get the range then even
need to collect all whose combos is just
all words yeah this is way better than
c'mon I'm not utilizing his movement
staying out there is betray and
controlling the mid range like that with
those kids
Oh
kagemaru was pressing all kinds of but
earlier in the match up that last five
seconds he just stood there and took it
die oh man
ouch might had that boot up up to the
stick he's pressing every button bro oh
my he's got raged he's got a pain little
like he just lost but what a great
offensive display and scramble towards
the end of that last I think yet forced
to scramble situations and you eat just
came out the winner and it's just out
what oh my god high octane but if you're
kagemaru the way you played that hole
thank you that for that game you can't
feel too too badly about it I think you
can side from crumbling towards the end
right but I mean he played a good game
so far why did he crumble at the end
because he had the wall to his back yeah
he couldn't get out and now he has the
infinite stage luck he said he has to
get that out of his head and realized
that when he was playing that mid-range
using his signing threes and other moves
it was a very affect it was working so
his choice here of course is to go to an
open stage trying to eliminate that
situation where he had his back to the
wall definitely fun
Josie now one of the biggest pitfalls
and using Josie early on is he didn't
really have the ability to do Daddy in
the open area what best kind of change
now yeah she still has some decent
damage now she's using three so let's
see every episo-- able to help him out
at a nice cow tear for their pop
kagemaru thank you one of this
you've got the first column make down
County oh where are you going get up
nice how to clean read of not get up
cake akamaru
you can tell he didn't like losing the
first game that way he's ready to win
now yeah he's pissed about exactly
that's the thing about Takamatsu he is
emotional all right now nice right
trying to apply more control in that
mid-range Oh turn also got the hit in
the follow-up that's good good to
gentlemen
yeah decent damage as well able to
salvage something right Oh
[Music]
shout it guaranteed here on the floor oh
it's a combo I could have been it and
spit the bar was the thing even more
costly now approval from nice no doubt
China once again yeah yeah the dot the
jabs are doing a really good job to keep
kagemaru out when he's trying to go for
these big breeds like Carter Street
access to the jabs just keep it miry
let's just stop just yeah stop it
yep big downer here the diver
[Music]
into the mix up no he was in the right
rate so he didn't let it go though did
it believe oh wow clean over the screen
it's not not opting to challenge the
dashing in his face I love it that's
like Apple on the bezel
oh yeah the second in - oh yeah nice way
for the running one bin Laden ow on set
point to move into the winners finals
against but can't he do it
there's Peter nice counted lots of magic
words of Atlanta this set for tomorrow
bottom left corner your screen though
feel all dangerous right now
no way is he gonna make this comeback we
gotta get it his muse that Peter yeah oh
oh crap you might get a hit there we go
final round second game right here
and the star way to started go Japan
getting loud in theater right now yeah
Oh two cards in trouble getting a break
here for this table although oh my I
better come back come back let's copy
Mario - what's gonna happen what did I
say that come back from Cabo what a
piece
I already said people should listen to
me bro crazy I'm gonna get another
another fine to find around pull it now
a little more please that's it windy
final five around Cape what a comeback
from kagemaru that was such a clutch
low-budget you said it bro
you said it kagemaru is a momentum bass
player I mean that's what it's that kind
of moment that we expect that we come
expect from it yeah he doesn't get too
many opportunities he has not performed
too well on big saves of winnings travel
but this is the kind of situation where
he can just turn up this could be it man
you're in the crowd is so loud for right
now it's awesome and yeah [ __ ] assignees
are quite quiet man the one that looks
dressed
I mean look don't forget that first game
he barely won
yeah right he was down to the wire he's
fortunate situation with the wall city
was a god in that first game yeah
execute he hit the big win in the drop
to right the drugs can't feel good
either no definitely not as much as well
yeah only using a little bit of it mmm
let's see what happens here this is the
final match winner of this match is
gonna move on against book in our
winners are all back to Japan love it oh
no oh you could feel it you can feel the
confidence down talking louder for sure
man but he can't over accept too much
yeah he knows it has to say [ __ ] if
there's any time to do it now you have
to do what lucuma does not that meter
bigwigs prophet bit off nevermind he's
gonna build that meter pretty soon oh
he's put his back to the bullets what
this is not good
he's got a huge like lead here I mean my
everything's fine and low crazy no way
buddy punished
switch hi this is dill and the cop in
the walls right there he goes for a
simple component to simplified and it's
got a huge lead now try to finish it
with a myth though has rage available
but the sweeps gonna get the book
sitting on a meter and a half is looking
really good right now the clitoris
though to the wall heavy go thanks da
wall are you going back the other way
damage incoming Oh
yo damn it kaki bars the [ __ ] out for
sweet miss all will move into the
winner's final cigar pitchbook oh what a
crazy separately both these guys don't
okay kagemaru is not out of the
tournament a star losers lucky else
Mayhew winners finals Pakistan vs.
Thailand out here man crazy bill of fate
bill of doing the tink there you see the
Pakistani is there and this is boss
their fate all the way from Jordan he's
had enough man that was a six